okay
hello everyone it's me rayne wilson
and it's me reza aslan and this is
metaphysical milkshake and razza today
we're going to do a podcast a little bit
different
you mean like no pants no i already did
that on our dr jeff sacks interview
today uh we'll be having an open and
honest conversation with one of the
greatest singer songwriters of the last
few decades the one and the only ben
folds
welcome to metaphysical milkshake the
show where we go deep we get weird and
we search for the meaning of life along
the way presented by cast media and soul
pancake
she's a brick and i'm drowning slowly
i'm so excited about this i have so many
questions for him about music about
creativity inspiration i am the biggest
ben folds fan ever i'm so excited to be
talking to one of my musical heroes ben
uh for those who don't know is the host
of lightning bugs with ben folds a
podcast that celebrates with some of the
world's foremost creatives about their
endlessly various artistic processes
well actually he's also a new york times
best-selling author he wrote a book also
called lightning bugs smart and you know
i think it's no exaggeration to say that
ben folds is one of the
major artistic influencers of his
generation and not only that but we will
be guesting on a bonus episode of
lightning bugs as well
which is also out today
and the three of us come up with a song
together no spoilers but it has a little
to do with poop but beautiful poop
yeah no exactly yes
beautiful song so head over to lightning
bugs with ben folds on his feed to
listen to the episode and follow rate
and review if you like it ben welcomes
amazing guests each week to break down
creativity including bishop briggs sarah
bareilles william shatner
oh
i want to find out about that and many
many more
wow what a thrill this is the great ben
folds is here on my zoom screen so nice
to see you ben very nice to see you guys
too let me tell you something if you
told my high school self
that one day you were going to be
talking to ben folds
that high school self would have peed
his pants i thought you're gonna say the
high school stuff would have said who
who's now conversely the the post
college grad rayne wilson if he was told
that he was gonna be talking to ben
folds would be seriously thrilled and i
just want to say with
with all uh sincerity
i had a cassette tape in my van i was a
man with a van in new york city i was
moving people's futons and i had a
cassette with your first two albums on
either side and i would just flip it
back and forth and pop in occasionally
i'd pop in a wilco or or or something
else but uh those albums brought me
great joy and uh through like every kind
of
nerdy white kid in the 90s and early
thousands so um
thank you so much for that thank you
that means a lot that's awesome yeah it
really and i i just loved all those
songs they're just in that in that sweet
spot of when you're in your kind of like
your early 20s and music is part of your
life and it's the soundtrack to your
life and when you're driving and you're
popping in a a song it's like oh
my my life has
uh
has come alive it's like i'm in a movie
i'm in a two-minute 37 second movie
music is so big yeah it's so big for you
when you're that age isn't it it's kind
of i i call it pop music you know music
for the mating age oh yeah i would just
like sit in my car and listen to a song
just so i could weep
you know what i mean
like dwight schrute did with everybody
hurts on the office you remember that
episode exactly
exactly or i would just like sit you
know i would listen to to all those
songs about longing i was a you know i
didn't have a lot of
girlfriends i guess you could say
or friends a lot
or any friends that
no but you know what's funny ben you
from what i understand like you always
wanted to be a musician right i mean
you've been listening to music
since what you were like two years old
totally yeah yeah yeah i was i was
just seemed to be really super
interested and obsessed with it when i
was when i was two years old yeah that's
crazy and you're doing so many exciting
things
and it's so great to see this other
chapter of your life but just going back
a little bit do you ever want to rock
again
do you ever just want to like rock out
with your [ __ ] out a little bit well
maybe keep the [ __ ] in i do
i do and and sometimes i actually do it
do it all the the the rock the [ __ ] the
whole thing it does happen i play with
symphony orchestras a lot and and um
that always goes down really well with
the orchestra the the moment you whip it
all out in getting to uh read about you
a little bit and um get to know your
life and your wonderful uh podcast
one of the things i was really struck
with because i have a similar
story
was the incredible failure that you
undertook in terms of trying to get into
the university of miami music school or
whatever it was
and you got rejected by them and you you
were a percussionist and then you took
your drum kit and threw it in a lake or
something like that
and
i guess i'm really intrigued by that and
i always zero in on on people's stories
when they've had
a failure that feels like their life is
over it feels like the book is closed
and yet what that did
and what that fueled thank god you're
not a percussionist you know what i mean
thank god you're not in like the orlando
symphony playing timpani right now uh
nothing against the tympanist at the
orlando symphony it's a lot of counting
it's a lot of counting playing timpani
it's true did you ever play an orchestra
razor i did i was a percussionist and uh
how about that 90 just counting and then
boom boom not as bad as the triangle
player though that's
that's true that's the counting and the
worst is missing it because it's like 93
bars
92
90
oh [ __ ] i'm curious about this too what
what part has failure played in your
success as a musician and i think and
y'all probably know this too
you have to fail it for nothing else to
realize you're still here it's okay you
know it's a scary thing to do to a fail
of it i can think of
you know certain shows that there's
nothing really romantic about the story
of the show except that i walked away
very certain that that was it like
that's just the worst and i can't
imagine bombing so badly
uh as a comedian like if you just add
that they didn't laugh it's bad enough
that they talk over your material but
they didn't
laugh that would that would sound like
failure that if you
once you endure that on a regular basis
you realize
the other side of it oh okay well i try
a thing i fail okay i'm not dead it's
fine next one i'll try something else or
i'll try it again maybe it actually
works and i did the same thing two
nights in a row
though the drum thing was horrible
because i went home and i worked at a uh
you know went back to north carolina i
worked as a you know a bag boy to a
grocery store for a long time just
thinking that that's it
my life is now i'm a bag boy because i
flunked out of the university of miami i
got in a fight guy beat me up threw my
drums in the lake i had a scholarship
actually they let me in on a scholarship
and i lost that and got kicked out
you know it's funny because i remember
having a conversation with jason
sudeikis way back in the day and his
dream was to be a member of blue man
group he was doing improv in las vegas
and every year he would warm up and he
would try out for a blue man group and
he would work on his drum skills and
walking like a blue man and and every
year he kept getting rejected by blue
man he's like oh god damn it
[ __ ]
i just want to be a goddamn blue man
and so then he's like well i'll move to
new york city and i'll start writing
comedy and then he got onto saturday
live as a writer and then a performer
and then the rest is history um but
thank god
you're not a percussionist thank god
jason sudeikis is not a blue man yeah
you know he he helped me move my piano
one time uh when uh when he was at ku
when he was in in uh in college i think
the other the other uh aspect of failure
that i just wanted to touch on is you
know for for me uh i won't do the long
i'll do the super short version of the
story but i got cast on my first
broadway play
a couple years out of acting school and
i sucked and to it was it created all
this pressure i really thought like i
was going to get a tony award and a new
york times review and get signed at the
william morris agency and i had all this
pressure on me and i was terrible and
it it it caused like a series of almost
like cathartic nervous breakdowns of
like the the snotty crying
but basically
through that catharsis
um i really embraced who i was as an
actor which is i'm quirky and i'm weird
and i have my own way of doing things
and [ __ ] them [ __ ] the man and i'm not
gonna like do it for someone else i'm
gonna do it for me and i always say that
when i tell the long version of that
story that i never would have played
dwight schrute had i not failed at my
first broadway gig so
how does a how does that pain of failure
kind of
fuel transformation well i think that
maybe what what what someone who hadn't
been through it would maybe focus on
would be more of
uh working through the pain of it to me
it's more um
it's more about the post the post-death
experience realizing that that's not
really death it gives you a freedom for
instance i i i had a long-term failure
in almost my entire 20s the same songs
that were on side a of your cassette
tape our first album i walked around
with those songs from the time i was
like 19 or 20 years old through to when
i was about 27
and i was rejected for that whole time
and at the end of it i just decided you
know what [ __ ] it i'm not doing this
anymore i'm not kissing anyone else's
ass i'm not making another demo tape
if you want my music you can buy it so
if i played a show and a record company
said you know we'd like uh uh could you
give us a tape i was like nah i don't
really do that you can buy it as music
and otherwise i'm not interested in
being on a label i've really meant that
and and just knowing i could go it alone
and knowing that
there was no uh safety net like if
you're
if you think you're auditioning for the
man and and they're gonna
guide your career you're not gonna say
or do what you mean but as soon as
they're out of the way and you realize
wait a minute
there's no approval system here i have
to make music that works for those 20
people
that's all that matters and if that
means i'm going to just do something
ridiculous
that's fine but when you're auditioning
you want to show your date manners like
you want to be polite
and i think that that was a big thing
for me is i was no longer polite about
anything did actually give no [ __ ] at
that point because i knew i had failed i
was done i was i already failed you
can't cancel me i'm canceled yeah it's
giving zero shits and all the doors that
that opens that's amazing it isn't weird
because you kind of feel like it's like
being uh aloof with the universe listen
this is all a very fascinating
conversation as someone who has no real
experience with failure i'm fascinated
by what you guys are talking about
you know the other thing that i'm really
fascinated by
ben is i love that you know you're an
incredibly creative and artistic person
it's just that most people know you for
i don't know like the primary way in
which your you know artistic nature and
your creativity has expressed itself
which is music
but you're also a writer you're a
photographer in fact you've had photos
published in national geographic which
is
a big deal
people don't i don't know if people
understand that's a big [ __ ] deal uh
i'm just curious like
how do all these different art forms
kind of work for you do they do do you
use different parts of your brain you
know when you're writing or when you're
playing music or when you're you know
doing photography or is it just sort of
different platforms for the same
sentiment the same expression
i i think
for someone like
and this is probably true of of you guys
too uh you know you you can have
interest in other things and i love
photography and i spent so much time in
dark rooms printing my stuff
uh photographing i i spent as much time
sometimes
doing that or more than i have in the
studio
but for some reason as soon as i make
music i'm very well aware
that i have a voice for it like like
there's something and it probably comes
from a little bit of that failure we're
talking about a little a little bit of
the out of the shits to give is that i i
don't
i look this is what i do
and take it or whatever that's what i do
and i know that it is what it is
when it comes to photography i'm always
trying to please
you know i'm always worried is that
cropped right can i stick that in there
would so and so have done that is the
contrast right should i have a darker
black like all these things i worry
about because i think that they're
correct answers and they're incorrect
answers and i realize humbly because of
that i will never have a voice
as a photographer i'm pretty good at it
but i won't have a voice at it
i may not be as good at music as i think
i am or as other people think i am
but i'm quite confident that what i i'm
doing is what i intended to do you know
and um i see people who are great
some are really great that struggle with
that sense of delusion that what they do
is for some reason
worth putting out there or is unique in
some kind of way i for some reason don't
understand that i shouldn't be doing it
and i just do it i don't even know about
the disciplines helping each other like
i'm not sure that like my composition
and music helps my composition in uh in
photography or in writing i i i'm not
aware if that's the case i just know
that i'm very comfortable in one art
form
and the others i can try as i may it
makes me appreciate another thing is
people talk and shop
you know i used to be a real [ __ ] about
that someone wants to talk about little
music [ __ ] like the microphones the
number of the microphone and stuff and
i'm like kid that's not why you make
music it's in your hands
and and i love talking about that [ __ ]
when it comes to uh to lenses like well
i really love my 35 millimeter lens it's
a 1.4 and i love that i realized because
i love that so much why should i steal
someone else's joy if they want to talk
about the action on on a piano or
something like i should appreciate that
so it made me nicer
look you all know there's just so much
going on in the world right now whether
it's stuff you're excited about like the
long planned office reunion that will
never be made
or the stuff you'd rather not think
about like the long planned office
reunion
that uh is never gonna be made you can't
control the vibes out there people but
you can always control the vibes in your
head with a pair of raycon wireless
earbuds in your ears have you tried
these rain i have they're fantastic i go
running with them whether you use them
to pump up wind down work or work out
raycons are
the go-to
for the on-the-go audio and every new
everyday earbuds look feel and sound
better than ever you get three new sound
profiles to make sure that everything
you're listening to sounds its best with
just the right amount of bass raycons
offer eight hours of play time and a 32
hour battery life there's also this
built-in mic so you can take your calls
on your earbuds at the press of a button
and raycon start at half the price of
other premium audio brands but they
sound just as good so right now
metaphysical milkshake listeners can get
15 off their raycon order at
buy raycon dot com slash milkshake
that's by b-u-y-r-a-y-c-o-n
dot com slash milkshake to save 15
percent on ray-cons
by raycon.com
milkshake
folks the seasons they are a changing
and so will your personal taste are you
ready for something new folks freshen up
your fall with a change in decor
all while upgrading your comfort that's
where brooke linen comes in brook linen
was started to create beautiful high
quality home essentials that don't cost
an arm and a leg and people what a
success brook linen works directly with
manufacturers to make luxury available
directly to you without the luxury level
markups you know what i'm talking about
so get their amazing array of products
at a reasonable price brooke linen has
something for your every comfort need i
literally woke up this morning in
brooklyn and sheets and i'm talking
buttery soft breathable sheets they also
have plush and absorbent towels cozy
robes comfy loungewear that you'll want
to put on and never take off in fact
brooklyn is so confident in their core
products that they come with a 365 day
warranty and listen
i'm a fan and i can tell you fans are
confident about these sheets they've
received over 75 000 5 star reviews and
counting so give yourself the comfort
refresh you deserve and get it for less
at brooklyn all you got to do is go to
brooklyn.com and use the promo code
milkshake to get 20
off with a minimum purchase of 100 bucks
that's b r o o k
l i n e n dot com brooklyn.com
don't forget to enter the promo code
milkshake to get 20 bucks off with a
minimum purchase of a hundred dollars
that's brooklyn brooklyn.com
promo code milkshake
one of the quotes i was struck with from
your book is this idea of luminosity
and artists pursuing luminosity and
that's very funny because actually i
just recently changed my twitter bio to
uh
something like something very
metaphysical milk shaky like i'm gonna
misquote my own twitter bio but it's
like yet just another luminous being um
having a a spiritual experience in it in
a human body or something like that but
so i i love that word luminous but but
that might be something that connects
both of these arts uh from your personal
expression and uh connects all artists
is is that what we're ultimately
striving for uh i love that phrase
striving for luminosity what does that
mean to you
i use the the um
the metaphor of uh of lightning bugs uh
because
it is they are luminous
but
it doesn't last for long
you know it's like they light up and
then you're like where to go where to go
and that's the way i feel about making
things is like it lights up and you're
like i got the
where'd it go where'd it go yeah that's
like that's sorry to interrupt but
that's like me with the office nine
years lit up on the office and after
that like where
my life has been a [ __ ] [ __ ] show
you know you were lit up and then and
then you where to go
half of the battle then as an artist is
is hanging on to it finding it it's one
thing to be inspired and we can all be
inspired but then you gotta have to do a
lot of work to
to if you want to put it in a bottle you
want to put your lightning bug in the
jar and carry the luminosity around you
have to have the skill to go hunt it
down put it in the jar not kill the poor
little [ __ ] and then you know
you've got a lightning bug in the jar
and and i i do think that like light is
a great you know uh is is a great part
of that uh metaphor also in the day you
don't see the lightning bugs and i like
the day as as a metaphor for awareness
of technique
and awareness of of of the of your mind
being on and and this is why i couldn't
do what you guys do
at all because
i choke real easy
and um i i feel like my light comes on
like my i get my head you choke really
easy i saw the video that has five
million views with you lead creating a
song with an orchestra in 10 minutes
effortlessly with pure pure creativity
there was zero chokeage going on there
what are you talking how do you talk
talk to me about that oh yeah i guess so
you've got a point i can do that uh i
guess it's back to music again but like
i did a tv show for five years on nbc it
was a singing show called sing off yeah
and every time they would put either cue
card or say will you say this or i had
to be ready it's like five four three
okay
like i just like i would just freeze up
and could do because i would get in my
head it's like what does this look sound
like should i slow down is my southern
accent too much like i just i had a hard
time with it what i love about
luminosity is um
the spiritual teacher abdul bahas
has a quote that says we must become
light incarnate and i think there is
we can see we can feel this okay this
isn't a scientific thing but every
person you meet has a certain light
right you you can see the light in them
it doesn't matter what they do they can
be an accountant and they can have a
light so we all have a light to give to
the world we have a light inside of us
and we can give that light to the world
absolutely and we do it in different
ways and artists do it through making
music or playing characters or whatever
and reza does it by writing you know
academic abstracts in publications that
no one reads and also making love we all
have our ways
of shedding that light onto the world no
no no that's well stated because i think
a lot of people
um uh worry about numbers uh and and and
eyeballs and stuff and um
and i think the reason that what you
said really works is because i think
that we've all made stuff that
people didn't see
uh and
i took it really seriously still proud
of it
still do it no one heard it no one saw
it and
and and it i can see how you people
might feel let's say that your day gig
is something
an accountant
and then you make beautiful music at
night you know the the uh the composer
uh charles ives
uh he he was an insurance
man he ran insurance business uh turn of
the 20th century and at night he just
wrote music
uh turns out to be he's one of the most
innovative 20th century uh composers
looking back uh in in american history
and uh he was doing tonight but no one
was listening to it at all and uh and i
think it's important to tell people what
you just said like there's light coming
from what you do you're emanating that
and
there's no one else that's doing it like
you if you're being true true to
yourself the other thing that i like
about the metaphor of using you know
luminosity is
the the pursuit of creativity is that
it works really well when you think
about collaboration as well right two
lights coming together make a brighter
light and you've collaborated obviously
with
you know a whole host of different
artists and all of this i should now
admit is nothing more than a transition
to talking about william shatner what's
william shatner like
i know i love that guy man i have known
him
he did a thing for me um i actually
i i wrote a song for him
in high school kind of finished it in my
first year of of college and i i
intended for
shiner to do this
and i i i looked up his agent in the
library oh my god and i mailed it
and i got a form letter back and here's
what it sounded like
she's a brick and i'm drowning
slowly
exactly
once he does it that way the next time
it's completely different and so i
didn't think about it for years and then
as soon as we had a hit
my first thought was well i want to make
an experimental rare because i know no
one's going to give me money to do this
as soon as we're not famous anymore
so i want to do that and i'd love to
have shatner
do that song and so i got you know kind
of got that song together and we sent
you know a note over to him and we had a
top five hit and so he was into it and
he said he'd show up and do it and he
was on his way to the studio and i
realized the song sucked it was like
i just really looked at the song i was
like this is just so bad and so i
totally rewrote it i i made it a whole
new song kind of put down a piano part
and he spoke over and that was like 1997
such a long time ago but he was awesome
then
uh his friend told me
um
uh you know bill
spits he chews up and he chews and spits
out directors and direction you will not
direct bill shatner just take my word
for it and i did like i told i always
was that wasn't good and that's great
and can you do it again and we had that
relationship i ended up producing his
record
i i gave him [ __ ] the whole time and he
loved it he was awesome he did things
so unusually he never does it the same
uh twice at the very end i i given him a
little too much and he said benny you're
pecking me like a chicken
i'm sorry forgive me i'm gonna i'm gonna
toot my own horn for a second so my wife
and i have a non-profit in haiti that
does arts education for girls
um
and
i have firsthand seen the ability of the
arts to
transform
people and also to transform community
to help build community and you're one
of the few artists out there on the
front lines kind of championing kind of
state-sponsored art support political
art support and funding in the schools
and in the communities and
you know god bless you for that that is
a conversation that used to be really
big and like there was talking about
that in the 80s and 90s like oh arts
funding arts nowadays there's so much
the world's about to blow up no one
really talks about arts funding but it's
it's so important what's your take on
that what's your mission on that i know
you were meeting with a lot of
politicians and are you still active in
that movement
i am yeah because i really think you
know it's like
you gotta pick up a shovel at some point
and chip in and you can't do everything
you know and uh i think that has been
my thing because i feel like
i i feel like let's just if if we're
gonna buy into the idea that we're just
going off the cliff and and humanity's
just just lost just lost it
that the best restart will be growing
great minds like okay we've [ __ ] the bed
so sorry
at least at least at least give the kids
an education and you don't have a great
education without solid arts in the
education you just don't that's that's
you could support that with with data
drop out data and anecdotal uh testimony
for years and years and years all the
politicians know it all the parents know
it the teachers know it so i think the
thing to do is is
is is to make sure that the government
invests strongly in uh in music
education arts education
uh across the board because you can do
it privately and when you should you
should donate to things and do these
things privately
but it takes an operation as big as the
government to reach everybody
otherwise uh
people just picking and choosing you you
have to hit all the area codes and all
the zip codes and it's very important to
have the data to do that i think it's
also important because symbolically
if your government that you elected that
are the is the representation of all of
us together if our collective idea
is that
spending on one of the most important
things for a childhood
is so small that it can't be measured
what does that say about the whole
symbolism of it what does it say about
us this is what's so important here's
the here's the stack that we're spending
on other [ __ ] and you can't even measure
one little way of showing how little we
spend on the arts all together in the
federal government is to say that if
we're spending equally for the entire
year
and it's like something like seven
million a minute i can't remember how
much it is but it's a lot like per per
minute or per 20 20 minutes go by
and we spent on the nea
uh uh uh
pbs
uh the kennedy center all
the things that we spent that goes down
in 20 minutes
we're done the rest of the year spending
equally around the clock for the entire
rest of the year you never touch the
arts again it's 20 minutes on the year
that is that tells me that that people
don't care about it
and and what i find when i go out in the
real world is people deeply care about
it yeah so i feel like it's a not it's a
not controversial thing you're not going
to talk to even the meanest
meanest like you know
just jabba the hutt [ __ ] you
come in and talk to is not going to say
i hate music i wish your kid didn't have
music they don't say that they just say
how you're going to pay for it and if
you can show them yeah but but they will
say and they have said and they will
continue to say the government should
not be in the business of funding the
arts well i think what's fascinating is
that the arts are sort of a
kind of shorthand for the values of a
society yeah right
exactly
it's not just about you know funding so
that people can have a musical education
or you know an artistic education it's
about like what do you hold dear as a
civilization right in fact when we talk
about civilization the great
civilizations of the past we talk about
two things
the buildings they left behind and the
art they left behind right and so i i
think it's yeah it's more than just
about
you know a certain kind of uh politics
or a certain kind of uh you know
emphasis when it comes to education it's
about you know what does your
civilization actually stand for right
this is this is what we are going to
leave it's powerful and there's also a
good economic argument for it i mean
uh the the the arts are a very that's a
lot of money moving that moves a lot of
money and even small like you know most
politicians want to know that their sort
of rural con constituents out in the
middle of nowhere are going to get
something for these things and if you
show them look the nea put a little
money into this theater they fixed an
old historic theater up and they put
some money that it was matched by seven
times the amount of money in private
funds which is the the formula so if you
you know the nea doesn't go into a place
and just start spending commie ass money
what they do is they insist that that
locally they're matched by seven dollars
for their one in private investment
that place ends up flourishing there's a
coffee shop there's a parking lot next
to it pretty soon you've got
you know you've got kung fu fighting
across the street
hey reign big news in shoes do tell
rothys rothys is now selling men's
sneakers and men's driving loafers in
fact even more big news they just
launched premium merino wool shoes for
the fall marina wool for those of you
who are uninitiated is nature's perfect
material it's soft comfortable machine
washable and sustainable and it's
available in cool colors and classic
styles that you'll want to wear
everywhere so if that wasn't enough
rothy's just launched their first ever
collection of accessories for men
they've got wallets carry bags card
cases rothy's has all your everyday
carry essentials no more worrying about
keeping your wallet clean after weeks of
wear rothy's wallets are fully machine
washable too i really do like these
sneakers uh they're they're it's a
really cool hipstery design the rs01
sneaker in crimson uh they are fantastic
and uh i am going to be getting a
thousand pairs well if there's one thing
i know about you it's that you are a
hipster so the these are the perfect
sneakers for you anyway
to help you welcome fall season in style
rothys is doing something special that's
right they're giving us the chance to
share this super rare opportunity with
our listeners for a limited time
right now you can get twenty dollars off
your first purchase at rothys.com
slash milkshake that's rothys r o t h y
s dot com slash milkshake head to
rothys.com milkshake to find your new
favorites today
you know you may not know this uh about
us but we have this podcast you're
actually on it right now we are all
about big questions and so what we
thought would be fun since you know it's
not every day you get to have ben folds
on your podcast is that we would have a
special episode where instead of us kind
of you know waxing philosophical about a
particular subject instead we would
invite
all our listeners all
dozens
of our listeners
uh to call in with their questions
their big life's questions
and uh and you know we'll give you we'll
give you a little shot at trying to
answer some of these we'd love for you
to be our third wheel today you know our
our co-host on this journey um and dig
into some life's big questions so what
do we got lined up dj
hi reza and rayne my name is andrea hope
and my life's big question is how do you
find the balance between pursuing your
ego and pursuing your potential so
sometimes it can be really difficult
when you're trying to make a decision
to think am i doing this to get
attention or to get likes or follows or
to put my name out there
but at the same time you don't want to
not do things that you have the
potential to do because you know you
could really positively influence other
people so especially being in media and
the arts and everything i was curious
yeah how do you find that balance
between being driven by your eagle and
being driven by your potential this is
right up your alley ben that's right
let's see i would say that when i am
trying when i realize that what i'm
trying to do
uh is
too approval based i feel a little sick
and nervous talk about that a little bit
more ben i'm sorry just because you had
mentioned this once before and i want to
make sure that andrea
understands what you mean by approval
based well we're in a business where
it does need to you know
the three of us could say we don't care
and and she you asked the question we we
don't care what anyone thinks we don't
need your approval but at the end of the
day you start to realize you make more
money you have more friends life is
better for you if people approve of it
and so it has to be taken into account
somewhere
uh but i believe when that balance is is
is out when what you're trying to do is
is is is get votes
uh or get money or get clicks or likes
if you think this is is furthering uh
your career no matter how you justify
that
i find i will feel a certain kind of
nervous
that's just me i'll feel a little bit
nervous if it's a way of singing i might
lose my voice like if anything off
people are gonna love it when i'll sing
that
and then i'll lose my voice because it's
not me and um i think it's the nerves
and i think most people would recognize
that like you've busted into a
a candy store and you're getting ready
to eat too much candy like there's
something wrong with you i totally
relate to that and as an actor
it is this perilous balance because your
success is predicated on people liking
you so you walk out on stage or you walk
in front of a camera and your film or
your television show
you know plays and people are either
like i'm entertained by you
and it isn't something you made it isn't
like oh here's this poem i wrote
and do you like these words on the page
it's you it's your face it's your voice
yes you're transforming into a character
but so there is in every actor there is
that narcissism of like do you like me i
hope you like me sally fields like you
love me don't you you really do like
that's underneath every actor there is
there is some kind of broken child
energy in there and at the same time
just like you say if you do it for the
approval seeking
you know you're you're doubting yourself
you're in your head you're pandering to
your worst qualities there you can kind
of smell the reek the scent the oily
perspiration of like that that wanting
need of
of being liked and being loved so you
have to find that way in to
you know honor that part of yourself
that wants to be adored and at the same
time uh find your own path uh to
um to to making it about the work so
always when i talk to young artists it's
like they'll talk about what should i do
in my career and should i do this and
should this is like if you just focus
focus on the work like what is what are
you expressing what are the stories you
want to tell how do you want to tell
them what do you have that's special
that no one else has like go go with
that go with that expression i think
for me the the
the ego
in all things not just the arts but the
ego
is uh is the enemy you know it's um it's
there for a very good reason so we have
to honor the ego the ego has kept us
alive right it it uh it keeps me fed it
has kept humanity uh thriving shall we
say kind of thriving for a hundred
thousand years but at the same time it
presents incredible obstacles you know
of self uh
of a needy self gratification at all
times so one balance that i have uh to
our fine caller is
for me like social media is both super
helpful and super evil and super toxic
so i've taken it off my phone i don't
have it on my [ __ ] phone i don't look
at i don't read if i spend time
if i have it on my phone i'm reading the
comments and if i'm reading the comments
i'm on a roller coaster i'm on an up and
a down of like oh they like they thought
oh this guy doesn't like me oh they like
that oh they think that's not this
person
my whole goal as a human being is to not
be on the roller coaster right i want to
create my own
you know
rides at the amusement park uh to
stretch out that terrible metaphor so i
both use the pluses of social media that
i broadcast what i'm doing and support
friends and causes that i like but i'm
not caught up in that kind of like day
to day minute to minute thumbs up thumbs
downness of the uh toxic internet and
you probably feel if you were to just
have a moment of weakness and put it on
your phone or go through that stuff you
will probably feel that nervous feeling
that i'm talking about there's a there's
a heightened anxiety i remember hearing
a psychologist once say that just saying
i me or my talking about yourself
is noticeable in vitals when you're
taking vital signs you will see people's
blood pressure elevate slightly pulse
elevate slightly and i think that's what
you do you're thinking about yourself
you're in your in your ego head and it's
actually not healthy that was pretty
great let's go to the next one yeah next
caller hi reza and rayne this is susie
meister
i wanted you to ask ben folds what he
thinks it is about music that is so
transcendent we see the way that it can
unite people in collective effervescence
at uh religious services and at concerts
and i want to know what he thinks it is
about music that can create that effect
great question susie
music is communication that's that's the
simple answer to it it is nothing but
communication and it's communication
that drops the guard
of of of the listener if i want to get a
point across
and i would try to get that point across
with statistics in a political speech
people put up great skepticism
boundaries in front of them and they
fold their arms music unfolds the arms
and brings in something that's actually
human
human beings have evolved with sound
and ears into the brain music lights up
the whole brain and the reason that it
does if you go into a brain scan while
speech only lights up a small two small
places one called the broca's area
that's like the size of like a walnut
but music goes across the entire brain
the reason that is i think probably from
talking to anthropologists on my show
is that
we
depend on musical stories for survival
if you're laying in bed and you hear
some things sliding down the hallway and
there's no one in your house you're like
okay what's sliding down the hallway
does that sound drunk does it sound
angry you can tell if a sound that's if
someone's dragging trash can down the
down the uh uh
alley behind your house you could
probably tell if they're angry if
they're drunk if they're young uh which
direction they're going what the thing
is made out of maybe what's in it and
that's an amazing amount of information
story information to be getting through
your ears into your brain i believe that
music is is the recent hijacking of all
that incredible
uh uh brain power
to
have fun tell stories make art make
people cry and laugh and i think that
it's just tied into the brain and that's
and we can't get away from it and almost
anyone who thinks that they are tone
deaf
will recognize
songs they'll recognize pitches relative
[ __ ] i can show you they're hearing
and recognizing a you know like a a
minor third they hear that and they
can't tell you that's what it is but
they hear it so i think that's what it
is that was
pretty [ __ ] awesome thank you ben
next i uh
don't know what i want like the outcome
of my life to be
like if i want to change something or
like be remembered
i'm just kind of sitting on that right
now
okay i'll remember that yeah i will not
forget that that's something you said
that i'll remember that's all
i could almost put that to music do it
you could you could put that phrase to
music into music well let's listen to
what he said one more time and see what
the key phrase is i uh
don't know what i want like the outcome
of my life to be
like if i want to change something or
like be remembered
just kind of sitting on that right now i
don't know what i want
my life to be
yeah i mean i think there's i'd have to
like look at the lyrics for a little
while but it seems like he wants to be
major a little bit because he's kind of
having fun with this i think isn't there
sadness there though there's kind of a
this
yeah that's the sad that gives it a
bitter sweet thing because instead of
going to a typical major normally go one
you know but i love that phrase i don't
know what i want the outcome of my life
to be and there's almost an iambic
pentameter there isn't there yeah
next up we got renee my life's big
question is
do you ever sit and wonder
why we can lie
not why do we lie
but what actually gives us the ability
to speak something we know isn't true
well this is actually a really
fascinating uh question and i do wonder
uh sometimes uh
well if we're talking about like
evolutionarily speaking there's actually
a very interesting
notion about why it is
that human beings lie like what is the
evolutionary reason for it and i think
the sort of prevailing theory is that
lying
helps to foster cooperation
right that it's like if you if you're in
a group you know in a cave or in a
village or whatever
you can sort of
foster closer bonds
in your group
if you can
lie in order to manipulate people into
cooperating
right and in fact
i read somewhere that like
the like the most cooperative
uh species
primates really are the ones that are
more the most adept at lying to each
other so it's weird to think that like
lying began
as a way to foster you know cooperation
amongst a group i read a similar thing
about gossip yes me too gossip uh
backbiting has actually helped build
community and galvanize community and
it's evolutionarily speaking been very
positively adaptive i think both those
things are true you're trying to
you know honestly win friends and
influences and
influence so you can galvanize
people to cooperate and do things
there's a great book uh uh uh by a
professor uh jonathan goschall called
the storytelling animal
and it's about it's about just exactly
that you know and i'm sure it's a common
theory but the whole book is about that
and it's fascinating and there's another
one by um
uh augustine fuentes
uh uh the creative spark about
creativity and and and human evolution
and so much of it is about
food
and about stories about just
making up lies
telling people stuff that's not true and
he mentions gossiping so i think those
are all on it right because what lying
does is it like changes the function of
your brain
to start thinking about things that
aren't real
and as those cognitive processes start
to get more and more used to you
sort of envisioning and communicating
about unreal things things that are not
true whatever then you can see why that
would then foster creativity eventually
and storytelling storytelling and
storytelling is lying you know once upon
a time there was a giant who lived on
the hill and he
asparagus every morning for breakfast
that's a lie
it's also interesting uh you know
why i think she wonders too maybe how
you can
even justify it or or morally if there's
not something inside you that thinks
it's wrong but if it's been working for
the human species
is it true that i think i've read that
that there is a period of child
development where
you expect the child to lie for a while
and that it's actually healthy it's just
that you kind of got to get them away
from it i think it should be said that
there were a lot of uh
adaptive qualities that humanity has you
know our you know violent reactivity has
helped our species survive you know but
that at this phase in our evolution
perhaps it's time to let some of that
stuff go and there might be another
series of qualities that we need you
know on a
planetary wide you know global wide
level to survive to the next level
because
the lying the violence the gossip that
those are three that we've mentioned
those those are three of the kind of the
worst parts of what's happening
you know globally and internationally
and and in the media right now and it's
not helping us anymore so
can we move away from those instincts
that got us to this point again honor
them but move on hello this is casey
from kansas city
my question is
which golden rule do you prefer do unto
others as you would have done to
yourself
or do you prefer do not do to others
what you would not want done to yourself
that is all
ah they all double negative you know
metaphysical milkshake listeners know
that we've rained and i have talked
about this on a few different episodes
that
when you look at
so all the major religious traditions
not just living but also the dead ones
those that have
bothered to put any kind of legal
sort of you know
framework out there going all the way
back to the code of hammurabi for [ __ ]
sake
have had some version of the golden rule
but
what's fascinating is that
most of those versions is the don't
version that he's talking about don't do
something just that you don't want
happen that you don't want to not happen
to you and that was way too many
negatives but you know what i'm trying
to say don't not do what you wouldn't
want
someone else to not do
unto you i think the power and the
negative is that it allows for the
thought
so it's kind of like you may be capable
of thinking of some really horrible
thing to do
but the fact that you didn't do it is
virtuous
i think that gives it a little edge yeah
like i might want to steal
all those books
behind you but
i thought about it but i'm not going to
do it as opposed to
the positives which is just assumes that
someone is going to do those things this
again is another one of those kind of
evolutionary answers right you kind of
it kind of makes sense why
this concept of the golden rule would
arise in ancient civilizations in the
negative form because it's a way of
policing morality right don't do bad
things because you don't want bad things
to happen to you
and then as we evolve and as we have
more complex you know ideas of what
morality
is supposed to be you kind of you you
positivize it right to do good to others
because you want good to happen to you
well listen ben this has been so much
fun will you come back on the show
sometime and be our third wheel again
love to yes wait i got an idea
why don't why don't we do your podcast
now oh my god everybody listening to
this episode
switch on over to lightning bugs that's
right with ben folds and you're going to
hear the end of this conversation and
you're even going to get to listen to
rain and i help ben
uh create a song from scratch which is a
new experience for ben but as fans of
metaphysical milkshake know that i used
to be a rock star so it's totally a
normal thing for me pike
hey listeners
as you know we solicit questions on
speakpipe.com
metaphysical milkshake
uh you can also follow like rate and if
you review our pod on apple podcasts
in your little review you can write your
life's big question and maybe we'll get
in touch with you and bring you on the
show we love having fans listeners
guests on the show and today we are
thrilled to have eva
uh from somewhere in pennsylvania that's
a state i'm a little bit familiar with
due to a television show that i did that
she'll remain nameless and ava looks
like she's out in the woods in the trees
maybe she's in the middle of an m night
somalian movie right now i'm not sure
uh she does look a little bit haunted
but ava you're on the show welcome to
metaphysical milkshake thanks my
question was
how
do we raise healthy children
in this
usually evil
capitalist colonialist
world that we live in i have no idea
thank you so much for calling in i think
about that every day well i feel like
it's a really important question because
and sometimes you get these questions
that don't have an answer but
i feel like we got to figure out an
answer for this one there are some
answers to this there are some answers
and there's a couple of things that come
to mind for me because this is a very
important question
um
and it's for all parents but it's really
for all people because whatever we apply
to the raising of kids we can also
use on ourselves
i
one of the things that brought me great
joy as i was raising my son walter who's
now 17 was to be
um whenever there were ads whether it
was on a billboard a television
commercial a podcast whatever
i taught him to have a critical mind
about consumerism like oh look at this
ad that's on the tv oh they want you to
buy trucks why do you think they're
running a truck ad during an nfl game
oh interesting because a male audience
and then trucks uh and masculinity are
linked look at these men on this
commercial they're linking their sense
of themselves with the actual truck that
they buy and it's hauling capacity even
though most of them will only be using
it to commute back and forth
uh to the auto parts store where they
work or what have you um i don't mean to
denigrate truck owners uh but
nonetheless i do think that
raising kids to
look at the capitalism around them um
and the consumerism around them with a
kind of a keen critical eye
is really important so that they have
that perspective growing up don't just
allow them to just buy in
to
hey
more stuff makes us more happy and but
to notice kind of society's kind of
obsession
with
stuff
so that's that's one thing that comes to
mind i have a few others but reza what
what comes what what pops into your head
well look my wife and i uh you know we
we actively um pursue this um idea with
our kids in fact she's got an entire
company now called altruist which is all
about
teaching kids empathy um and i think
that's the word
empathy is the word i think so often
whether it's about teaching about
consumerism or you know colonialism or
the the evils of the world if you can
narrow it down to i'm going to
teach my kids
how to empathize with other people
everything else i feel like kind of
falls into place so one thing that we do
a lot in our
is that
on sundays uh we have a dinner that we
just sometimes refer to as like holy
chow or whatever where we talk about a
particular issue um and you know we kind
of go around the table and we just kind
of talk about what they think about the
issue um oftentimes um because my wife
you know works with um
uh people who are dealing with you know
economic or social or political
injustice and so we will
for instance if we're if we're talking
about refugees you know we'll say things
like
um hey you know we've moved before can
you imagine if you were
suddenly forced to move tomorrow and all
you could bring with you is a backpack
like what would that be like um
and
then we talk about how well you know
there are millions of people mostly kids
who actually do experience that they're
called refugees
and just taking these very complex
things around the world that that you
know that they're sort of being
bombarded with you know in media and and
stuff and then figuring out how to
connect their lives to it so that they
have this modicum of empathy so when we
see homeless people what we'll say is
like hey what do you think would happen
if you didn't have a home
it's not just that you'd be tired then
you'd be you know cold or you'd be sick
or you'd be dirty but could you go to
school
no you couldn't even go to school could
you because you don't have you know
clothes and you don't and you're and
you're filthy you know what would it be
like not to go to school and then now
every time they see
homeless people they they get it in a
sort of visceral and emotional way
that's how kids understand i think so
often we try to
teach kids
like rationally uh or we try to quote
unquote educate them you know about
the troubles of the world there are
these things called refugees and this is
what they are and this is what happens
but that doesn't it doesn't strike kids
uh it doesn't stay with them but if you
try to build empathy by making it part
of their experience at least i have
found
kid
my kids just absolutely
burst over with kindness and compassion
and empathy
for people who are who are facing
situations that are quite different than
theirs and that's
kind of all we can do one of the
perspectives that i have is that
yes in the current world there are
tremendous forces of disintegration
they're everywhere they're forces of
disunity of judgment of vitriol of hate
um
and there are systems that are
collapsing there are systems that are
just simply broken like health care
let's say and it's just getting worse
and worse and worse there are also
forces of integration there are also you
know the black lives matter movement you
know the metoo movement there are uh
various coalitions of people coming
together to try and make the world a
better place you know like greta
tonbergen um you know the friday's
campaign of of young people so to always
direct your children to see both clearly
oh look there's disintegration but let's
not focus on that there's forces of
integration and positivity yeah let's
work for that yes let's put their
attention towards those things sometimes
they may be harder to find than you'd
like but that's where your focus needs
to be put because if you just spend all
of your time looking at everything
that's falling apart you'll get
overwhelmed and you'll never be able to
accomplish anything ava anything come to
mind for you do you have kids is this
just something you're worried about
i guess would work
get worried about
there's so much bad
and it's important
to know that not everything is
great you know you want to raise kids
who are
gonna see what's wrong and think
i don't like this i'm gonna figure out
something else
but then
you could
these kids get there's the depression
and the anxiety
you definitely can't
just like lecture
your 10 year old you know yeah
but
there's these times when we'll be in the
car
and we'll have these conversations
between us
and they're so much more invested in
like what are the grown-ups talking
about we can have like these heavy
conversations
in front of them and just hope that
it's rubbing off a little
do you and your partner uh ever
do acts of service volunteer work we
really don't have the time for that
right now well even if something is as
simple as planting a tree
or um collecting
uh food from your pantry and dropping
them off at the at the food kitchen just
demonstrating through your actions
your commitment to making the world a
better place
like kids will
pick up on that you know long term over
their lives ava thank you so much for
your call and uh it's really nice to see
you and that was a terrific question and
really one of the most important
questions there is
so listeners do you have any thoughts uh
please share them with us um at rayne
wilson reza aslan on the social medias
you can also connect with us at
metamilkpodcast on twitter and at
metaphysical milkshake on instagram we
would love to hear your life's questions
and we'd love to hear your answers
to this very important question from ava
ava thanks for calling in thank you so
much
metaphysical milkshake is executive
produced by rayne wilson reza aslan and
colin thompson it is produced by safa
samazadeh yazd harris lane mick dimaria
hashem self and dj lubell
cast media is the production and
distribution partner it is edited by
tyler newbold original music by jeff
tang
[Music]
man i have an idea for your next musical
venture perhaps with a very very very
large symphony the band folds 500.
oh [ __ ]
we gotta find a stage big enough
for my ego
hey thanks for watching you guys for
more fantastic videos just like the one
that you watch please subscribe to our
youtube channel thank you